when we say our observable universe or
just our universe for short we don't
mean all of space we mean this the
region of space from which light has no
time to reach us during the 13.8 billion
light years since our Big Bang meaning
there is plenty more outside of this
that we have yet to have the light come
to you probably we haven't seen it yet
but every time we wait one more minute
light reaches us from another light
minute away when more stuff comes into
view
we've never suddenly had come in to view
a sign saying space ends here you know
little universe is constantly opening up
yeah it is it is so what we need first
of all is a hefty dose of humility
because we humans have again and again
made this mistake of thinking that
everything we knew about was everything
that existed just discover that that was
just a small part of a much grander
structure right a planet a solar system
a galaxy yes our universe is that we
were the center and then we weren't the
center we were in just the storm and we
have a long track record on hubris
so humility is all good yes now how much
is there actually well pretty much all
of my physics colleagues think that
space is a lot bigger than than this and
again every minute we wait we see in
fact more the most popular theory we
have what main are you our space in the
first place this made it so big called
inflation actually predicts in the
simplest versions of space goes on
forever forever and if that's true then
you can fit infinitely many other
universes regions into this where there
will also then be galaxies and
ultimately yeah if you roll the dice and
things thought I'd randomly copies of us
having all sorts of very into this
conversation this is what I call the
level 1 multiverse and if it sounds
weird it's only the simplest four levels
and I want to make sure this is
explained so max is saying we are at the
very center of this yeah not because
there's anything magical
it's just that if you're ever walking in
the fog and the visibility is a hundred
meters you'll feel that you're in the
centre of your own little fog sphere yes
and that the extension of the universe
goes in all the directions in infinite
amount from here and that the reason why
there is this red ring around the center
is because this is where are the disk of
our galaxy yeah this is just the photo
of the edges of the part of you space
that we can see take in with microwave
cameras on this necessarily W map that's
taking baby pictures of by looking at
the light that's been traveling for 38
billion years to us seeing that when a
universe was thought was four hundred
thousand years old and it was super
awesome twenty pens as you said to 40
cents for American 20 cents per American
to make these tremendous discoveries so
next time you think about the money
that's being allocated towards science
give those big thumbs up - yeah I've
never met anyone who would forfeit one
bite of a burger for these deep secrets
about the cosmos